they'll take their swings off of jorge
lopez making his 23rd start of the year
and lopez starts it off in style he
strikes out lau
on a knuckle curve lopez's 0-2 is a
beauty
slider got crews looking and jorge lopez
has two strikeouts here in the first
[Applause]
meadows down looking three strikeouts in
the first inning for jorge
lopez and two of them backwards case
for the tampa bay rays this afternoon
will be michael
walka the right-hander making his 15th
start
to face michael walker cedric mullins in
his 15-game hit streak will
kick it off first pitch swinging
cedric mullins right field ain't gone
cedric mullins welcome to the 2020 club
his 20th home run to go with 21 steals
he doesn't even breathe he takes the
first pitch from michael walker
out to the flag court
there's a ground ball brushed to third
and 3-2 joey wendell on the run wide
throw
and mancini safe at first base
and to run around for anthony santander
he swings to the first pitch and loops
it into left field to base hit
mancini's gonna go for third and trey
is out
a double in the series for franco
bronco goes to right field base hit
santander will stop at second
the orioles have three hits in the
inning
and it's lifted into left here comes
meadows
to make the catch and out of all that
only
one run scores one-nothing baltimore
and mateo must have gotten stung by that
by his reaction jim reynolds with a
delayed call
mateo will go down to first on a hit by
pitch so there goes mateo
this is going to be easy for jorge mateo
no
chance in the world for mejia well this
is a situation richie martin
got to be good in martin chops 1-2 and
through the right side
and mateo with a late break will come to
the plate
safe a ferocious
head burst dive in for jorge mateo
who scores on the bouncer from martin to
make it two-nothing
on the exchange from glove to hand and
they got to be really good throwing
richie's off
martin on the move and wins with a base
hit martin went into his slide
he'll get up he'll get up for third he
is in there
[Applause]
and he shoots this one down to low on
the
low lighter and he gets the double play
how about that
right there you see winds let it go by
and he's headed to second base
so martin not able to advance from third
he's there with two down for hayes
austin hayes will take care of that he
will score martin from third
and rbi single for austin and the
orioles have a three nothing lead in the
second
the pitch to mancini is swung on the
miss strike three his best change up of
the day
so far mancini fans orioles get
two more runs and at the end of two they
lead the race three nothing
payoff pitch and he gets rung up lopez
punches it up to 96.
nothing into the count to the raised
catcher
he swings and hits a high fly ball back
into right
santander is going to go to the corner
leap and that balls off the top of his
glove and off the wall
already around second on his way to
third mejia and he has himself three
bases allow came
into the game four of six against lopez
on the ground and through the right side
into right for a base set
mejia will score lau comes through and
the razor on the board 3-1 the score
payoff pitch cruz swing and a miss he
goes after a sinker at 96. it's another
punch out for jorge lopez blind ball
center field santa nair and gone
anthony santander slugs one to center
a cracking home run his seventh of the
season
the orioles second home run of the game
and the birds are teeing off against
michael walker here in the first three
innings
and the man lead it off is austin
meadows he sends this one deep to right
this one will be fair and
is out of here home run
well meadows kept that one fair his 21st
home run of the year and the rays
pick up another run trim the deficit to
two
and austin wins drills one toward the
left field corner it'll be his second
hit
wins is digging for two a single and a
double
for austin wins austin hayes in rbi
single as last time
that ball is ripped by hayes phillips on
the run not gonna get there
back to back rbi singles for austin
hayes
sizzling on a sunday runner on the move
and a cut and miss mancini out on
strikes meadows on the ground
picked by trey here comes the covering
lopez a terrific play at first base
made by trey mancini it's a rocket off
the battle one hopper and a really good
backhand slide a nice feed like a
quarterback
leads a receiver oh
this one slips away and johnson just
hurt himself
and the raised staff out there quickly
to attend to this dj johnson will leave
two outs here so shagwa replacing
johnson a little tapper left side
wendell's throw will be in time
[Applause]
offense here down five to two
[Applause]
high fly ball deep to left the other way
this one's gonna go
home rod off the bat of brett phillips
that's number seven
as he connects off cole salsa
and the rays trimmed the deficit down
they trailed by two in a 5-3 game
[Applause]
and a lighter base hit off the first
pitch
mullins in to make the pitch up
[Applause]
brandon lau against the lefty is aboard
and there's ball four first two men are
on
on three and two to cruise and it's low
ball four
and the walkathon for paul fry continues
that's popped up martin is backpedaling
mugs coming in richie martin has it and
martin
will throw it to the plate cut off by
mancini
the runners hold and fry records a major
first down
and he walks him stayed away
that's going to make it a 5-4 ball game
where dylan tate is going to be forced
to throw strikes
and his first one into diaz he swings
and hits it
back into center field mullins there to
make the catch
tagged by luke lowe he's going to score
and the rays have tied this game at five
[Applause]
and that pitch is down it will be brett
phillips who homered in the seventh
sky to left field going back is austin
hayes all the way to the track
opposite field opposite field grand
slam for brett phillips and the
rays do it again in the eighth inning
phillips seventh home run and this one
clears the bases
the pitch strike three anthony's but
the eighth inning strikes again 2-1
and the ground ball to short bronco
with the throw to first and the rays
sweep it and they win this one
9-6